joe biden had said things would change
on the very first day of his presidency
for the thousands in the same position
as siomara martinez
she's from cuba and crossed nine
countries to ask for asylum in the
united states
but under a program begun two years ago
by ex-president donald trump
she was put back to wait in mexico
between her court hearings
she spent two years now waiting in
sierra juarez
for a decision
it's quite dangerous because we're on
the border we're not from here and
danger is present all the time
so we put our hope in president biden
and everything he promised in his
campaign
we hope he sticks to his promises
what joe biden promised was to end the
program called remain in mexico
which has seen more than 60 thousand
asylum seekers
put across the border from the us while
they wait between court dates
many were placed into gang-ridden cities
like juarez or matamoros
with his tank camp sprung up he hasn't
done that yet
what he has done is to stop enrolling
any new asylum seekers in the programme
but the numbers of those sent back were
already going down before his term
anyway
the real question is what will happen to
the thousands already stuck in mexico
will they be now allowed into the u.s
while their process
plays out jose luis alvarado a
nicaraguan nurse who fled the autocratic
rule of daniel ortega
is fervently hoping so he's been stuck
in mexico for two years
struggling to provide for his expanding
family without a work visa
mexico
what happens is that mexico isn't going
to give war to an immigrant
because it has many unemployed here if
you go to a factory
the first thing they ask you is are you
an immigrant do you have legal status
if you don't have a permit they don't
give you a job
i will introduce an immigration bill
president biden's already planning a
path for citizenship for millions of
undocumented migrants
who are already in the u.s
[Music]
he said he'll be more open to asylum
seekers too
the tricky part for him and his team
will be doing that without sparking a
rush on the border
stuck in the middle of that difficult
calculation for those in limbo
in mexico john holman al jazeera
mexico city